that's a dog but today's show is
sponsored by a shark that's right surf
shark
hello biggie you love surf shots do you
love surf shark yes he does you love the
shots of the surf he [__] loves it
what for instance if you like being
anonymous online which some people
really do because they want to go and
say bye
sexy underwear for their girlfriends oh
that's clever yeah that's smart but they
don't want that girlfriend or anyone
online to be able to know or see it
sounds like you're wanting to buy sexy
underwear for you
sometimes i like buying sexy underwear
for myself yeah fair enough mate yeah i
think i do i do think that men don't do
that enough lads treat yourself yeah go
on treat yourself put the vpn in and
away you go yeah so don't forget to use
our chords exactly yeah what's the
episode next time you're gonna wear some
sexy underwear think of geordie i feel
like this is more of a brand deal for
underwear alerts no it absolutely is a
brand different surf shot cause if you
want to go anywhere else in the world
and put yourself digitally in that
country then you could say log on surf
shock on any one of your devices because
it's available on all of your devices
laptop pc phones you've just been to
america i've just been to america so you
could use it
if you if you want to like go back there
digitally digitally you can and here's
the crazy thing about it if you use code
geordi then you can get yourself 83 off
three months for free and there's a
30-day money-back guarantee that if you
don't like surf shark they'll give you
your money back that's confidence that's
confidence it's confidence in a product
imagine that just being like if you
don't like it you get your money back
where else would you get that imagine
saying that in the supermarket they
wouldn't have exactly i don't like these
oreos
exactly not happening i mean brian's
tried it before yeah halfway through the
pack and you realize there's so much fat
on here yeah yeah
i thought this was turkey anywhere which
is by the way another place you can go
with your vpn don't forget the link is
in the description below use called
geordie 83 off money back guarantee 30
days
thank them and us later enjoy the show
[Music]
a moment of silence for the death of
true news
back [__] welcome back to true
news you asked for it you begged for it
so some of you may have heard of a
podcaster called joseph rogen is his
name joseph i think it might be right
let's just say it is yeah for sure uh
basically the reason i started doing
podcasts when he started he was just
talking about ufos and bigfoot and
smoking weed with his mates which who
doesn't love that right you know over
the years more and more people started
listening to joe organ and before we
knew it i think he had like 11 million
listeners on average which is a lot
11 million in terms of podcast that's
big also probably bigger than most the
mainstream channels that are sort of out
there no actually if you combine all of
the mainstream and put them together
it's probably still bigger than that
which is why that's a lot they might not
really like him very much because he's
one man with a few cameras he's
independent basically he can have his
own thoughts his own conversations right
and he has not being told to say stuff
to you guys by anyone these new shows in
america are all backed by big
corporations and there's a narrative
that they have to tell you they're not
like joe rogan and he's dangerous
in their eyes but what they're trying to
say is he's a danger to you not to them
he is a black belt so pretty dangerous
in their eyes this is killing two birds
with one stone right have a go at joe
rogan see if you can cancel him but also
make sure loads of clicks while you do
it because people are going to want to
see your news story about joe rogan
clearly so either way they win they
either get views because they attack joe
rogan or they get views because joe
rogan's no longer a source to just
refresh your memory part of the reason
why joe rogan is now all of a sudden
this big deal is because he signed a
hundred million dollar deal with spotify
and in the process started giving some
political opinions about does he prefer
bernie sanders does he prefer donald
trump what does he think of joe biden
and the minute he entered that game the
war had begun and later on when covey
hit he was obviously talking about
alternative treatments and he was
talking to different doctors and
professors and again the government and
the mainstream media don't want someone
else having that level of power to sway
people away from their message so he is
enemy number one right now
misinformation and making money off of
it disinformation i should say she's
literally misinforming us about the word
misinformation joe rogan has been at the
center of controversy for comments that
he's made about the pandemic in vaccines
spotify has been pressured to do
something about it but it stood behind
its most popular podcaster and now rogan
is under fire for some new comments from
an episode this week cnn's paula newton
joining us live from ottawa the way this
woman's like this is terrible like her
old facial expression this is truly
awful let's see what she says maybe
she'll be balanced i want to see what
happened here what did he say
yeah brianna this was quite an epic
conversation great way to describe the
jurgen podcast she loved it big
subscriber and the issue is here people
tune in to joe rogan because there are
no guard rails to the discussion that's
why they listen to him many call the
discussion ignorant and some found it
incredibly hurtful listen
not for the first time the joe rogan
experience not for the first
time rogan experience does this i just
love the way they talk do you know what
else i love is i love her tone is she's
like a disappointed head mistress that
you've just wandered into yeah so you
wander into them she goes listen brian
it's not for the first time that i've
had to have you to be honest i've found
them chat's more arousing than the way
she's
that's another story yeah you shouldn't
talk about your actions in school not
for the first time the joe rogan
experience featured contentious canadian
psychologist and author jordan peterson
this time for over four hours
they would do with this to be fair for
our podcast [__] mental no but but
who's got the time for that [__] you
know that's the thing though it's the
way they say it as if they've broken
some kind of law like i had a
conversation for over four hours
late into the night and it's unusual
that they spoke for more than 20 minutes
yeah is that not against some sort of
covered law yeah exactly yeah yeah in a
free-ranging reductive back and forth
about topics peterson has no expertise
in
i love the way they've deliberately
picked a video clip of peterson looking
like an absolute mentalist this is a man
who was literally a doctor he is one of
the smartest guys online right i don't
agree with everything jordan peterson
says but he is smart if you have someone
muted and you're talking over them doing
weird hand actions of course he looks
like a nutter and that is their goal
here right and why would cnn want to
have a puppet joe rogan after he brought
one of their presenters on and
humiliated the [__] out of them after he
said why cnn lying about me and the
presenter shut the bed and had no clue
what to say but forget the agenda let's
just see what they've got to say so you
think that a lot of what's going on with
people that want to change their gender
identity is creativity no i don't think
so
so what do you i know so there's no such
thing as climate right climate and
everything are the same word
and this one on race i am white actually
that's a lie too i'm kind of tan this is
like a four and a half hour podcast
they've literally scanned it and went
what are the worst three sentences and
fine right that out of context make this
look shocking the amount of things you
can take out of context and make them
look ridiculous or evil or silly it's
literally become an art form on youtube
there's literally videos where it's
called out of context because it is so
funny that's kind of what worries we're
we're adults now back when we were
teenagers and something like that we
could be easily manipulated we're now in
2022 when people are so easily
manipulated into believing that things
set out of context are just genuine and
not as literal as what the words have
just been said with probably 15 minutes
of setup completely sure so one of the
main things that the media have gone
after joe organ on is his personal um
treatment cycle that he sort of put
together for when he had covered and
it's something that he is offered out to
all of his close friends celebrities and
the like and dana white backed him up i
tried it he said it worked the wonders
for me now this is something where joe
rogan's got a lot of money the
celebrities have got a lot of money i
think the fact that he was even coming
out with it frightened the mainstream
media a bit because they're going let's
get everyone vaccinated that's what they
wanted their approach is one size fits
all and the problem with what joe rogan
said from their perspective not his was
well i've got a different size over here
and actually it works pretty well but
they were like just shut up we need you
to do the main thing being that he has
said look i'm young i'm healthy i feel
fine i don't personally feel the need to
take the vaccine the minute he said that
they instantly were like we have to take
this guy down for whatever reason
they've tried to do that and
you know from the ivamectin um that he
was taking which was prescribed to
hundreds of thousands of people in
america was then all of a sudden turned
into it's a horse drug and we need to
make joe rogan out to be some crackpot
homemade [__] medicine guy and that
was one of the main things that cnn went
after him for and as it happened he made
a mental note of it got a cnn guy on his
podcast and basically said why are you
lying why life
what happened
didn't go well by the way i'm glad
you're you're you're better i'm glad it
only lasted a day you're probably the
only one at cnn that's glad no
the rest of them are all lying about me
taking horse medication
we should talk about that that bothered
you it should bother you too they're
lying at your network about people
taking human drugs versus drugs
calling it a horse to worm is not a
flattering thing i get it it's a lie
it's a lie on a news network and it's a
lie that they're conscious of this is
not a mistake i think what joe's saying
there is they're willfully misleading
people in their information they're
literally misinforming people did you
see that thing that the fda put out what
did the fda put out
it was a tweet and it was snarky i admit
it they said you are not a horse you are
not a cow stop taking this stuff or
something like that why would you say
that when you're talking about a drug
that's been given out to billions and
billions of people a drug that was
responsible for one of the inventors of
it making the nobel prize nobel prize in
2015 15 yeah yeah a drug that has been
shown to stop viral replication in vitro
you know that do you the thing is we're
like going so fast like i feel like i'm
missing a mystery you think i want that
that's a problem that your news network
was not lies
well i don't i don't dude what did they
say they lied what did they say i was
taking horse dewormer i used to feed
polos to horses right very dangerous as
well probably themselves
responsible is it yeah they're like
apples as well i'm told i think he's put
he's put his guests in a tricky
situation there because the guest
obviously has an interest in working for
someone who employs he wants to keep his
job but he also knows it's [__] i
think it makes it quite clear what is
true there because the guy can't reply
with anything so yeah we're going really
fast here what i do find interesting
yeah we're going really quick here
really quick what to the truth you can't
handle the truth joe rogan now has a
platform and has a perception with that
people know what the format is they're
kind of attacking a format that actually
seems to be worthless they're
deliberately misinterpreting joe rogan's
profession which is podcaster and acting
like he's a news reader and acting like
it's his job to keep the nation informed
you know if he is wrong so what that's
his problem and he will lose viewers
over that that is not the job of cnn to
attack
the fact that they have turned their
observation to him
shows it's about attention and about
viewing figures and about the war for
for you guys to listen to them because
they're clearly losing you and why are
they losing regular people because we
don't trust them anymore why is that
because they keep telling us one thing
and then telling us another and another
and when when they get caught they don't
admit i was wrong but you know who does
admit they were wrong
right that's why his credibility is up
here and regular news is down there is
because they will never admit they are
wrong and we know that the same for the
politicians you can't trust them that's
why people are turning they were
podcaster not because we want to but
because we can't trust those [__]
what we're learning here is it's not
about the actual news corporation it's
about the people who own these things
and what their agenda is oh yeah they
want to talk to the top right yeah and
it's no different to what howard stone
had years and years ago it's no
different to howard stern yeah jon
stewart anyone with a platform that
seems to be giving people information
that is counter to what a lot of the
mainstream or or even or even just
considering it even having a
conversation and that is the main thing
that we've seen in the last few years is
censorship shut down the conversation
there is one message and anyone who even
questions it you're a crackpot you're
you're a nutcase don't even i'm not
saying he's always right but i'm
defending the right for him to have
these conversations and be wrong i
wanted to make a video to address some
of the controversy that's been going on
over the past few days this is another
great reason by the way why people
follow joe rogan they feel like they
have a direct line to a guy that they
can have a real relationship with they
can judge him as a person they can judge
and judge what his intention is and he
can just go on his platform and speak
this was one take this wasn't cut away
to another thing we're gonna go to a
news break now we're gonna go to an ad
break this was just him speaking
honestly for and not like and now for
the news right the podcast has been
accused of spreading dangerous
misinformation specifically about two
episodes a little bit about some other
ones but specifically about two one with
uh dr peter mccullough and one with dr
robert malone dr peter mccullough is a
cardiologist and he is the most
published physician in his field in
history sounds like a quack to me dr
robert malone owns nine patents on the
creation of mrna vaccine technology and
is at least partially responsible for
the creation of the technology that led
to mrna vaccines what is that you know
about vaccines i'm all right quite a lot
quite a bit
sorry both these people are very highly
credentialed very intelligent very
accomplished people and they have an
opinion that's different from the
mainstream narrative i wanted to hear
what their opinion is you can watch this
whole 10 minutes for yourself but as you
can tell joe is very calm he's
explaining that this is the joe organ
experience not joe rogan news and it's
him asking questions to experts who may
have different opinions and that should
be appreciated it shouldn't be something
that is just like shut down and censored
and this is getting more and more
aggressive towards him and that's what
freaks me out he's a reasonable man
right and he gets things wrong and if if
you've watched your organ as long as i
have and i've watched him pretty much
from day one there's been times where
he's been high as [__] off his face with
his friends saying dumb [__] like that's
what we love about him he isn't perfect
he isn't always right and he will like
here admit where he's made mistakes or
that there should be warnings or you
know spotify maybe can have a warning
before his podcast to say you know do
your own research and all of that sort
of stuff you know what i mean but it's
the way he's having to defend himself on
a weekly [__] basis yeah a real issue
is that they don't want to look at a lot
of the people who did actually handle
kobe badly for instance a government on
either side of the atlantic so it's very
easy to say to someone like joe rogan
well you stopped people from getting the
vaccine because you said this i mean
literally me it's a [__] joke and yet
the people who were supposed to be
protecting us actually giving us the
right information [__] up religiously
in the news and the government
politicians constantly making mistakes
breaking their own [__] rules the
fact that this guy's getting it shows
that the media are a tool of the
government and not there that questioned
the government and this has never been
more obvious now like joe rogan is
getting more analysis of what he says
than the actual politicians who are
boris johnson has been caught lying more
times than i've wiped me off in my life
and yet they're not attacking them the
way this guy gets right exactly and that
would be my point here is there's not
only does joe rogan deserve to be
evaluated and by all means do that but
in context he's a podcaster not a
politician you can bet your bottom
dollar that they're going through every
joe rogan podcast with a fine tooth comb
cnn all of them will have like a hundred
employees just listening around they're
probably sitting one actually that's
pretty good this is i see why people
should do a format like this
and you know they've picked out every
time he's ever used the n-word which i
don't agree with i love joe organ but i
would never agree with that and you
can't condone it and clearly joe rogan
instantly as soon as he realized there
was an issue did apologize but but the
way they're reporting it is if he's used
it in a way that is directed at someone
almost as an insult without any context
now i'm not saying that makes it okay
but it does make a difference right like
context is important people uh have the
ability to learn and change and part of
cancer culture and part of what the news
is perpetuating here is the second you
make a mistake you don't deserve the
right to write that mistake or to say
hey i actually made a mistake here you
basically take it down don't leave it
there anymore and if that happened with
the news we wouldn't have any news
networks left what we're allowing people
to do here is frame all of this through
cancel culture and there is one end that
people want to meet with this which is
take him off the platform don't give him
a deal don't allow people to speak if
they can't say what is generally agreed
upon and it stops proper conversations
from having it's a misunderstanding of
what actual public discipline you know
the problem for them is though if they
do take them off the platform guess what
the next day the platform he starts
becomes the platform right so who's
really the platform is it spotify or is
spotify on joe rogan's platform because
he is that big they're basically a
partner with him he didn't own him like
the minute they let him go he's laughing
he's creating his own thing next thing
you know he's even richer than before so
they're just gonna keep trying more of
this and expect it anything else that he
said at any point any joke that he's
made every stand-up thing he's ever done
they're calming and they're looking and
if you're a fan of joe organ he's
probably gonna need your support more
than ever in the next few years the
white house has actually urged spotify
to take further action on joe rogan now
i'm annoyed that joe rogan is getting so
much publicity right like what do i have
to say don't go down this can we i've
heard that having coveted makes you have
a bigger dick so is it really that bad
right what do i have to say to get this
kind of cookie i must have had a lot of
coverage at what point i had a [__] ton
of covered what point will 10 downing
street come after us and say we need him
off of youtube because i want that kind
of coverage i think the problem is
you've got to be of a certain level of
fame for anyone to give a [__] if you
got taken off youtube people would just
go that's true who jordy it's our
overlord you know the guy who you said
to be the worst prime minister ever a
couple of year ago oh that's trendy to
say now i'm gonna get my [__] high
horse for a minute when we couldn't get
views off it when it wasn't about oh i'm
just gonna do something crazy and
that'll show boris johnson that who's
right we were talking about this and we
have people criticizing us and spamming
us in the comments and saying you don't
know what you're talking about boris
johnson just is he's trying his best
that was literally the comment boris
johnson is trying his best well guess
what guys boris johnson's best was
partying while none of us could go and
see our own [__] family to be fair
that's me at my best that's you at your
best so
yeah you're really a bit harsh there i'm
being a little because i know me at my
best right belly full of whiskey right
yeah and boris definitely got the belly
for it i understand
and share the anger
up and down the country at seeing number
10 staff
seeming to make light of lockdown
measures seeming to even now boris
johnson can't admit that it wasn't
seeming to they were making light of
these measures own your [__] words
and i can understand
how infuriating it must be to think that
the people who have been setting the
rules have not been following the rules
stop gaslighting us he's like a [__]
toxic boyfriend i mean if you want to
think that then that's absolutely fine
you think what you want all right but
i'll be over here on my own because i
was also furious to see that clip i
think he was actually furious about
seeing the clip but not for the same
reason that we were oh i watched that
and went
what the [__] boris johnson went oh what
the [__] how did this get out the rules
of times tory politicians went on the
news and said we followed the rules
throughout all of those parties it's
like do you actually hear what you're
[__] saying the point was you're not
supposed to have the [__] parties in
the first place you prick that's the
rule so if you have a party you wouldn't
follow with them that's boris johnson
there furious at the idea that a party
may have been had i for one stayed home
alone for christmas didn't go and see
anyone missed both my parents my son's
first christmas a lot of people were
like looking at their grandmas through
glass and stuff like that absolutely
yeah and boris johnson they hadn't put
them in a glass case or anything right
she's not all of them not all of them so
it's a window right okay and of course
in solidarity with the country boris
johnson did exactly the same a photo has
emerged of the prime minister in downing
street on the 15th of december 2020
surrounded by alcohol food and people
wearing tinsel
but he had no idea though he had no idea
he had no idea he's sitting in his
office going why are all these people
munching on cheese and crackers drinking
wine and listening to spice girls what
worries me is is this no different to
any other day in downing street another
day hitting the voddies and making the
laws am i right it looks a lot like one
of the christmas parties he told us
never happened in what he has just said
i'm afraid he is completely in error
cicinera let boris johnson on your way
hell you should be speaking of the prime
minister have some respect for a man
who's of such high order the photograph
referred to is all over social media
everybody can see the photo the prime
minister is in the photo everyone can
see the photo i don't understand why you
won't just acknowledge it boris will he
refer to the map the matter to the
police because this is not one of the
parties already being investigated by
the metropolitan police
that's precisely the point mr speaker uh
it already has been uh it already has
been that that event already has been
submitted for investigation and you know
what the mad thing is right there was
like people saying goodbye to their like
dying relatives and there was people
like who missed opportunities to have a
final christmas with a relative who then
later passed away and this guy's having
a [__] jolly up i [__] knew this
would happen so i ignored the [__] the
whole time i'm left with no regrets me i
had a good christmas fantastic christmas
i i did have a good christmas i just
didn't have a good christmas with my
family i wanted my dad there on the
christmas days you know what i mean
didn't have him there on christmas day
that's what i'm saying that's what
pissed me off i didn't want my dad there
on christmas day i didn't invite him
absolutely yeah but that's your progress
no phone started yeah right do you know
what i mean i wanted my dad there didn't
have him
nadine education secretary and i will
use their first name because we're on
terms like that as basically said and
i'll read the headline pupils shouldn't
criticize boris johnson in class as
education secretary people should not be
criticizing boris johnson as part of
their coursework the education secretary
has said tori is reacting with anger on
wednesday after it emerged that children
at a school in nottingham have been
writing letters critical of the pm's
behavior
as part of an exercise did they do this
on a tunnel and tell the students like
you must not criticize your prime
minister everything he does is always
correct you should be able to criticism
enjoy your prime minister he loves you
do you remember when um the tory party
said save the nhs yeah and then said
that people who work for the nhs must be
clapped every thursday remember that and
then i clapped
and then they got us all obey all of the
ridiculous rules that were put in place
which basically restricted us to do
anything we [__] wanted to do in the
name of save the nhs after they've
underfunded for decades and then they
tell the people who work for the nhs
well if you haven't got the vaccine i
don't care how much natural immunity
you've got you're getting sucked in the
morning save the nhs yeah i said they
said save it well apparently they're
they were all going to be sacked so
you've got all of these people who've
given their blood sweat and tears to
save people putting themselves at risk
for years literally and then told thanks
for that but we'll be saving yourself if
you don't want to get a vaccine then
they just go back on it you talk about
misinformation how much misinformation
do you want to go through in that sac
the nhs save the nhs you're hired you're
fired if you do want to hold the
government to account do remember that
there were 8.7 billion of losses on ppe
government accounts says 8.7 billion
just
up in the air
goodbye what about the app the truck and
trace we don't know that was another one
even more even more on that that's a
whole other set of money over there
brian that's just another set of money
just poof do you remember when the joke
i just set the pile of cash off
absolutely yeah by the way the person we
have to question all of this is joe
rogan not sadger javid not any of the
people are responsible for all this [__]
but the person who's got the podcast not
the person who's actually responsible
for the laws and the person who signed
all these things off the people who
question that who's the more dangerous
person in the room here
he's got a black belt imagine if someone
set fire to 8.7 billion that's exactly
what this government did uh but enough
about that what what's on netflix
all right the tinder swindler it's
exactly what it says on the tin you know
uses tinder to swindler and basically
they should have seen it coming
there's there's this guy who they make
out to be some debonair [__]
christian grey billionaire type of guy
sweeps the women off their feet shows
them a lifestyle that they'll never ever
have without him and he makes them fall
in love with them now he makes them does
he put guns there and go fall in love
you know that's kind of how it is is put
across like
what chance did she have you know what i
mean and right i do think it doesn't
this documentary does not explore at any
point could you been a bit more switched
on it's completely he's bad they're good
i get it because he is such an [__]
even if they are slightly to blame for
their own downfall because
yeah and desperate for the cash and
maybe they were in love with them i'm
just going to suspend belief for a
second he is such an [__] that you
just [__] hate him and you do feel
sorry for these people right but if
louis theroux made this documentary
there would have been a bit of him ago
at what point did you think maybe you
shouldn't have been sending him the
hundreds of thousands of pounds because
you hadn't seen a penny of it back
you know this man for weeks i don't
think that they did a good job in really
getting into the gray areas of the
documentary you know were you just
really hungry for that lifestyle and
willing to do anything to get it i'm not
saying they were but the question isn't
even asked and i think most people sat
at home watching the documentary you're
like what like yeah i get you were
bombarded with all of these riches but
how come at no point you thought you're
asking for how much again like you know
a lot of them trusted they'd see it back
as well right i get it and the main the
main woman who talks about this is a
lovely person and you can tell she
genuinely i think she did love him
where's she from norway yeah definitely
not london london women literally you go
can you lend us a tenner and they go
[__] what love it's a fantastic
documentary where this guy has literally
managed to as i'm sure you've probably
seen by now escape really what he
deserves which is to say an early
[__] grave because this guy deserves
the worst decisive to die no this guy is
a he is a danger well let me be the
judge he is a horrible bastard through
simon's tick tock which is also the
official hopefully gonna be a great
flight
[Music]
right so what simon's managed to do is
and what i do believe this documentary
has done it's given him notoriety oh is
anything he's he's like the new dan
bilzerian or something [__] this guy's
like he's just banging models it
wouldn't surprise me if there were other
rich people out there that went how much
money do you earn i'll cover that let's
[__] weirdly this guy seems to be just
getting away with it and that's the
problem is like as much as you know some
of these women at some point should have
said what the [__] is going on earlier
they've been swindled and he is an utter
[__] what did simon do in bed is a real
question for me
because he's ugly as [__] no another
thing is like it takes all like
responsibility of of the handing over of
money right away from the adults who
were in their 30s i don't think that
they did a good enough job into looking
at why they handed over so much money it
was very much we were in love open shut
case he said he needed it there's a
point in the documentary which um he
realizes he's [__] and he's losing his
money and he needs help from one of them
and she's just [__] with him at this
point and by the way she's the real mvp
of this whole documentary there's one
girl who really takes it to him kind of
hot by the way anyway he leaves her a
load of ice notes and they are [__]
crazy
so and just just be clear this is the
man who charmed them you stop playing
game with me now stop
till you actually listen to me listen to
me you're gonna give it today you don't
understand where the [__] you going i'm
sorry about what i said but that's it
but you're taking the piece out of me
i love you and i care about you he's
wanting his um she took his clothes and
sold them on ebay and he's wanting the
money but of course when you say i love
you to someone you go i love you he's a
passionate lover he's a passionate lover
i love you you love me
you have no idea how much i love you you
just need to trust me one last time by
the way anyone who says you just need to
trust me one last time that's really not
the way that trust works
you know when someone goes trust me just
one last time what do you do one last
time i mean trust me we'll be together
forever you will never play with me give
it today
look elaine i'm sorry about everything i
give you the last [__] warning today
you want more you will get [__] more
you will get [__] more he sounds like
scarface than
yes this guy's a nutter gotta admit i
kind of love it like i kind of want to
meet him you know the guy is crazy and
this is the thing is as much as i've
talked about where the documentary
failed the one that they did neil was
this guy's absolutely insane and the
amount of bizarre fake scenarios right
he concocted to convince these women
that he had enemies and that he was a
diamond billionaire just listen to one
drake album he's sitting there going
enemies i've got a lot of enemies and
you're just like and they're like yeah
i'm buying this i'll give you a hundred
thousand pounds
wow these women basically just wanted to
date drake they reckon he's swindled
like 10 million quid off of people but
like i think it's probably more given
what he's driving around in and where he
lives it's probably more this is a
lesson out there to a lot of women by
the way aim lower go for a guy who isn't
you know yeah i mean every man is a
piece of [__] so just be careful the
piece of [__] that you go with no
absolutely and i know before i go and
see a woman i always look at myself in
the mirror and say you're a piece of
[__] now let's go and make her happy
right because you are a piece of [__]
now see how lucky you are right she
shouldn't even be anywhere near you she
shouldn't even be sitting anywhere near
your dirty little dick anyone out there
who had any hope that rihanna was going
to get with them and have sex with them
and make them happy men your dreams are
over i don't feel like you're talking to
yourself here
no but i do know some people who really
wanted to get rid of brianna yeah you
didn't find me under attractive no i
think she's pretty and all of that but
she's not my cup of tea oh come on rude
boy no but i don't mean this in a like
everyone's like i'm sorry brian i don't
think you were in the running i get that
right i'm just saying if i was gonna go
into the celebrity crush dimension she
wouldn't be the one but this may be the
greatest combination of jeans in rap
that we've ever seen oh this is rihanna
and asap rocky this baby can't be pretty
i don't know like beyonce jay-z
jay-z jersey's not attractless to you
you've seen asap rocky they call him
pretty flacco you're not seeing like how
cool this kid's gonna be by the way
rihanna seems very proud of the fact
she's pregnant yeah that way this is the
thing right to women out there look
you're gorgeous you're a goddess sure
could you wear a t-shirt over it what oh
you don't like the belly always out
because she's trying to be a documentary
if i walk out with my belly hanging out
everyone calls a fat [__] well you lot
oh you're blooming you're glowing yeah
how about no no one ever said it no one
ever says to brian no one has to see
your [__] belly right 4am on rocket
league no one ever looks at him
blooming the one thing that does grow
when you get pregnant i'd love to see
them the titties
the belly put that away the old milkers
as you call them the milk is over right
and we'll we'll be fine but look at this
for a combination of jeans do you get
any better than those two
he's [__] gorgeous he's all right she
is fit i get it look at that that what a
great couple he's he's an awry looking
guy he's all right what would you shug
him would you i love bad [__] that's
my [__] problem yeah i like have you
seen him i've got a [__] brother i'm
not being funny right he's rocking up to
a [__] award show in a [__] quilt
that he's not i mean brian what are you
doing what do you want like what you
don't understand is i'm not before he
looks ridiculous and she looks like
cruella deville anyway jealousy is an
ugly emotion uh that was true news it's
back it's bada than ever and we [__]
hate console culture and if you're
perpetuating it suck a dick we'll see
you on the next one don't forget hit
that like button click the sponsors all
of that [__] subscribe we'll see you
later don't forget to click the sponsors